[Music]
Mackie Saul had given every indication
he'd be seeking a third term as
Senegal's president that all changed in
one sudden announcement
my dear compatriots my decision after
thinking long and hard
is to not stand as a candidate in the
election scheduled for the 25th of
February 2024. I've made this decision
even though the Constitution would give
me the right to run again
Saul was widely accused of cracking down
on the opposition ahead of an expected
re-election run last month saw a wave of
violent protest after opposition leader
Usman Sanko was convicted on charges of
corrupting youth the government says 16
people were killed the opposition says
it was at least 23.
Funko says his prosecution was
politically motivated aimed at removing
him from the upcoming election now with
the president out of the running many
hope there will be peaceful days ahead
okay
you have to respect your word and it's
this respect that has led to this
situation from now on he will be highly
respected internationally
we need a president who takes pity on
the Senegalese we need a president who
doesn't kill his people we need a
President Who listens to his people
Saul's bid for a third term was
controversial
he himself held a referendum in 2016
limiting the presidency to two terms but
he later argued his first term prior to
the referendum didn't count I'd like to
um to congratulate all the Democrats and
and the young people who stood defend
Senegalese democracy because uh without
that President would have run it's also
a lesson for other African countries I
mean people need to stand when democracy
is a threat and and do what they need to
do with Saul out it's still not known
who his party will run in his place
nor is it clear If Leaving opposition
figures will be allowed to compete
Fenton Monaghan Al Jazeera